okay welcome back everyone so this is
the last week of class the second
midterm / homework 6 should have been
posted yesterday you all have access to
it and it's due at 4 o'clock on Friday
ok so this is the last week of all
homeworks exams and class and this is
probably my favorite topic that we're
gonna cover this week which is data
analysis and the singular value
decomposition so this is just kind of a
tiny peek into the wide world of data
analysis but I want to tell you about
some of my favorite methods and some of
the really powerful things you can do
with very very simple mathematical tools
ok so today we're going to talk about
the singular value decomposition the SVD
so the SVD is probably the so if not the
most important algorithm of the last
hundred years it's maybe the second most
important algorithm after the fast
Fourier transform and this is
revolutionizing how we deal with large
data sets this is really the basis for
how Google determines which pages to
rank first how Amazon determines which
products they think you're gonna buy how
Netflix builds a profile of what movie
tastes you have and the list goes on and
on and on ok so especially in Seattle
and San Francisco and New York City the
singular value decomposition is becoming
the most important algorithm for making
tons of money after grad school okay so
SVD is awesome it's a very very very
simple matrix decomposition ok so it's a
matrix decomposition and it's a very
useful matrix decomposition
okay so how many of you have heard of
the SVD before in some other context
okay good so some of you have heard of
it so the singular value decomposition
we're going to be able to do things like
build facial recognition software okay
so that's something that I'll do on
Friday we can start to look at the
genetic markers that are characteristic
of healthy versus sick patients so one
of the examples we'll do probably
tomorrow or Wednesday is look at the
genes for ovarian cancer and try to
determine which genes are or are not
responsible for ovarian cancer that
turns out that the singular value
decomposition is very useful for that we
can also do more pragmatic things like
well that's pretty pragmatic but more
simple things like figure out what
factors affect housing prices
what mixture of various parts will
determine the heat production from a
cement mixture and the list goes on and
on and on the singular value
decomposition allows you to take
training data from your past experience
and essentially build a model and
extrapolate what other situations would
look like okay so this is the basis for
machine learning which a lot of you are
going to be bringing into your research
in the next you know years and years
yeah even if you don't know it yet
machine learning is gonna play a part in
a lot of your lives ok good so the idea
is that the singular value decomposition
is particularly useful when you have big
data ok so good for big data and
everybody has a different definition of
what big data means my definition of big
data is relatively all-encompassing so
big data is data that's bigger than what
I can plot in 3d ok so five D data is
bigger than 3d but often times big data
would be like the results from a huge
fluid simulation that Boeing might run
or the results from a huge questionnaire
ok so the post office for I guess
decades and decades now has been giving
this gigantic
ecological evaluation to every single
person who applies for and enters the
postal service so they have millions of
employees answering hundreds of
questions and if you write down all of
the multiple-choice answers in a big
matrix you have a gigantic data matrix
okay so questionnaires fluid data
experiments if you wanted to measure the
seismic data on planet Earth or the
position of all of the stars or how
every senator has voted right this is
these are examples of big data and the
singular value decomposition is a way of
extracting the most important features
so we want to know what are the most
important features in the data sets
sometimes you call these dominance
features and what it means for a feature
to be dominant or most important is that
it comes up again and again these are
features in your data that you see over
and over again so they're strongly
correlated ok
so let's do some examples of this
singular value decomposition and start
getting a feeling for for what this
thing actually looks like okay so let's
say that I have a data matrix
X
and typically what I'm going to do is
I'm going to write this as a bunch of
column vectors X 1 X 2 X 3 dot dot X M
ok so X is an N by M matrix ok please
interrupt with questions at any time if
I start getting confusing or unclear
because I do I deal with the SVD like
every day and it might be easy for me to
go into something that I know that you
don't okay so the each column of this
data matrix X represents some big
measurement ok so this big measurement
could be this could be the temperature
measurement at all of the weather
stations on planet Earth on day one and
this would be the temperature
measurement at all of the weather
stations on planet Earth on day two day
three dot dot up to day M ok so each
column is a high dimensional measurement
measurement vector okay another example
is let's say that I have the fluid
simulation for a flow past a cylinder or
a volcano or something I could take the
fluid velocity field at all million grid
points and stack them in a really really
really tall million by one vector okay
and this would be the fluid velocity at
time one time two times three dot ah up
to time n so each column is a very high
dimensional measurement the dimension of
the measurement is how many pieces of
information I need in that measurement
and I have M examples of these
measurements
okay and so the M examples might be a
sequence of measurements in time so
often a sequence in time and if they're
a sequence in time then we call them
snapshots makes sense right you have
like what's you kind of imagining you're
taking data with your camera and every
moment in time you take a snapshot these
are each snapshots of data okay so does
it make sense how we're gathering this
data another example I'm just going to
keep giving you examples of data
matrices that have come up in my
research or my collaborators research so
this is a good example another example
you might take the number of infected
people infected with polio in every
single district of Nigeria so this might
be you know four or five hundred
districts in Nigeria and every number in
that vector would be how many cases of
polio you've had that month and each of
these snapshots would be that tally for
that month month 1 month 2 month 3 and
so on and so forth okay and so what we
want to do is we want to find examples
of things like are there correlations
between these snapshots are there places
in Nigeria that are just more prone to
having outbreaks of polio okay so we
want to be able to find dominant
features in this data set in a way that
we can actually understand what we're
looking at okay so the singular value
decomposition is a way of rewriting our
matrix X in the following way so we take
our big data matrix X and we write it as
the product of three new matrices we say
that it's equal to u times Sigma times V
Star and Star just equals complex
conjugate transpose
so technically the singular value
decomposition exists for complex data
matrices X like if you had the columns
of X came from a Schrodinger's equation
simulation the nodes might be complex
valued and in which case V would not
just be the transpose but it would be
the complex conjugate transpose we are
only going to deal with real value data
in this class and so star to all of us
should mean transpose just matrix
transpose super simple okay so we're
taking our matrix X and we're rewriting
it as the product of three new matrices
u Sigma and V and it turns out that
these new matrices are actually much
much simpler and better organized than
our original matrix and we can use these
for tons of things okay so I'm going to
tell you what the properties of U Sigma
and V are I'll tell you why they're
important and then I'll give you an
example
okay so U is an N by n square matrix
Sigma is an N by M diagonal matrix what
do I mean by a diagonal matrix just
numbers on the diagonal they're very
closely related to diagnose so
everything off the diagonal is equal to
0 and V is an M by M square matrix okay
so in the example that we were looking
at over here if this is the number of
people with disease in different
districts of Nigeria or this is the
fluid velocity at all million grid
points or this is all of the weather
stations on planet Earth
oftentimes our size of our column n is
much much larger than the number of
snapshots we have M
okay so for some examples for many
examples we have n is a lot bigger than
M so examples of that would be like
disease modeling disease whether fluid
modeling and so on and so forth
there are a few examples where n is a
lot bigger than n any like ideas what
some examples would be yeah the survey
is a great example or M might be much
bigger than n this would be the survey
what's another good example sometimes I
put electrodes I sometimes people I know
put electrodes and brains and they might
measure 10 different electrode signals
but they would measure them at 10
kilohertz
okay so they'd have 10 measurements of
bajillion times okay so like brain
measurements another example would be
the stock market so even though there
are tons of stocks you know if there's
not that many might be hundreds or
thousands but I have the stock ticker
for every second for the last 50 years
okay so I have more snapshots than I
have number of stocks and this is a
great example the stock market is one of
the most interesting data sets to
analyze with these methods and so
there's that's why New York City is in
the list of people that are benefitting
tremendously from the SVD okay good
so in a lot of cases that I work with
you is a gigantic square matrix V is a
smaller square matrix and Sigma is a
diagonal matrix that's the same size as
X okay now the last thing I'll tell you
about U and V is that U and V are
extremely special matrices called
unitary matrices this probably deserves
red
so U and V are unitary unitary so how
many of you have heard of unitary before
okay
unitary matrices are some of the most
special matrices on planet Earth
they're amazing matrices that have this
great property that u times U star is
equal to u star times U and that's both
of those are equal to the identity
matrix the N by n identity and the same
thing with V and V star so VV star
equals V star V equals my M by M
identity so these are extremely
extremely special matrices u and v such
that if I want to take the inverse of U
or the inverse of V all I have to do is
complex conjugate transpose it why would
that be a really useful property for our
matrix to have then it's easy that it's
inverses the transpose
it makes a commutative what's maybe a
more practical day-to-day reason easy to
compute so if I wanted to invert a
generic and by n matrix how extensive is
that order n cubed okay if I want to
invert a unitary matrix I just multiply
by its transpose that's order N squared
okay so it's way way way way way way
easier to matrix inverse unitary
matrices and they also have beautiful
geometric properties and all kinds of
other things so they preserve distances
if I if I take two vectors x and y and I
map them through a unitary matrix their
angle and lengths are preserved it's a
pretty special relationship only unitary
matrices have that property okay so if I
take any any vectors any pair of vectors
and I map them through you or I map them
through V their lengths and angles
between them are preserved super duper
simple and super powerful so the
singular value decomposition the last
thing I should tell you is that this
exists and it's unique for all matrices
X and these could be complex matrices so
all complex and by M matrices and I'm
not going to prove this if you want to
prove it you can it's in books you can
google it it's really easy to find a
very very simple proof for why this is
true but this definitely exists and it
is unique for every possible matrix so
any matrix you can name X I can give you
a you a Sigma and a V such that this
product equals your matrix and we have
these properties
okay so our is everyone with me so far
we have a big data matrix X it holds
lots of information that I care about
and I want to extract the patterns in
this data that are the most useful for
informing policy or design or making
money or selling products or whatever
you want to do we want to find what the
most important features of this data are
okay so the last piece I'm going to keep
saying the last piece there's just more
and more pieces of this that keep coming
so another piece of information about
the singular value decomposition
probably one of the most important parts
is that this Sigma matrix is a diagonal
I'm gonna draw this for n larger than M
is a diagonal matrix with what are
called singular values on the diagonal
and zeros everywhere else so Sigma's on
diagonal these are called singular
values the reason they're called
singular values is completely historical
like a hundred years ago people looked
at singular integrals and found out you
can derive the singular value
decomposition and that's not at all how
we derive it now but they're still
called singular values and they have the
really really important property that
Sigma 1 is bigger than or equal to Sigma
2 is bigger than or equal to Sigma 3 all
the way down to Sigma n em and they're
all either greater than or equal to 0
they're all positive or they're all
non-negative and they're in descending
order from biggest to smallest
and so this allows me to do something
really really interesting which is so
I'm just going to write this out
explicitly we have our data matrix x
equals u 1 u 2 dot u n the columns of my
U matrix right times Sigma 1 Sigma 2 dot
2 Sigma M zeros everywhere else times V
1 V 2 up to V M complex conjugate
transpose okay this is just what the
singular value decomposition looks like
but the fact that my thick my Sigma
matrix in the middle is purely diagonal
with zeros everywhere else means that
what this is really equal to is Sigma 1
times u 1 V 1 Star Plus Sigma 2 u 2 V 2
Star Plus Sigma 3 u 3 V 3 star plus dot
dot dot okay does this maybe I should be
explicit about why this is true so let's
take this matrix times Sigma so take V
Star Times Sigma so I get essentially my
V 1 salting is transposed so it should
really look like this should look like
v1 v2 dot VM star right and so what this
Sigma one in the first diagonal does is
it just pulls out the first row of V and
the first column of U and everything
else is multiplied by zeros that makes
sense yeah
the second singular value only
multiplies the second row of V and the
first column the second column of U and
so on and so forth and so what this does
is it breaks my matrix X down into the
sum of em rank one matrices each of
these as a matrix so this is a sum of em
rank one matrices does everyone know how
to yeah
it means complex conjugate transpose so
I mean you as a column vector in V as a
row vector so this leads them to my next
my next question so what does it mean to
take a row vector times a column vector
times a row vector so we know what we
get if we take let's say that I take a
row vector one two three times the
column vector four five six we know how
to do this right it's just 1 times 4
plus 2 times 5 plus 3 times 6 okay but
what if I do it the other way what if I
have a column vector times a row vector
how do I do that so the other one is
called the inner product this is called
the outer product and think about this
as like u1 and think of this as V 1 star
right if V 1 is real valued then I just
take a column and I turn it into a row
that's V 1 star so the way that I
compute this inner product first of all
it's going to be a 3 by 3 matrix and
these have the same inner dimension okay
they're both one on the inner so I take
four times this whole row vector 4 8 12
then I take five by this whole row
vector five 10 15 and then I take six by
this whole row vector 6 12 18 so this is
U 1 V 1 star it's a matrix ok so u 1 V 1
stars of matrix and it's a rank one
matrix and what do I mean by Rank 1
matrix all of its columns are linearly
dependent on the first one and all of
its rows are linearly dependent on the
first one so if I looked at this matrix
I would say that this the columns of
this matrix only span one direction or
the rows of this matrix only span one
direction they don't span all of 3-space
they'll only span one two
so this is a single rank one matrix okay
so writing this as u times a diagonal
Sigma Sigma times of V Star allows me to
take my matrix X and write it in a
series of rank one matrices this is a
matrix plus a matrix plus a matrix dot
dot and since Sigma's are in order of
importance each of these matrices is in
order of importance
this first matrix is the most dominant
contributing factor to the data in X and
the second Matrix Sigma 2 u 2 V 2 star
is the second most dominant contributing
factor to the matrix X and then the
third and the fourth and the fifth so
does that make sense so far
you have a question okay so this Sigma
matrix
I'll show you kind of where it comes
from but for now we just take for
granted that it does exist and that we
can write it in an ordered Sigma 1 2
Sigma M yeah in this case it looks like
you have another way the 0 is instead of
being below would be to the right
exactly so and yeah exactly if this was
like a cycle and tall skinny matrix to
use or short fat matrices and for a tall
skinny matrix the zeroes are below for a
short fat matrix the zeroes are on the
right yeah exactly
but you have the same the same sum of
rank one matrices this is called a
dyadic sum if you're interested
sounds druidic dyadic sum because these
are dyads u 1 and V 1 they're dyads and
because U and V are unitary what it
tells me is that the columns of U or
orthogonal to each other
u 1 is orthogonal to u 2 its orthogonal
to u 3 because otherwise I wouldn't be
able to get this identity same thing
with the columns of V they're all
orthogonal okay so these rank 1
matrices also span orthogonal directions
so when I add them up I build more and
more rank into my matrix X okay we're
ready for the final final final piece
and then I'm going to show you a matrix
example so the actual final piece I
think I hope this is the final piece is
that you can use this to approximate a
matrix useful for matrix approximation
so what do I mean by matrix
approximation how would I make this
useful for matrix approximation so I've
written my matrix x as a sum of a bunch
of rank one matrices I could always just
truncate that sum after the first couple
right I could just say well X is
approximately equal to u 1 u 2 u 3 times
Sigma 1 Sigma 2 Sigma 3 times you know V
1 V 2 V 3 star I could say that my
matrix X is approximately equal to just
the first three of those matrices in my
son because I know that Sigma 1 is
bigger than Sigma 2 is bigger than Sigma
3 so all of this stuff I'm throwing away
is small in some sense it's you know
Sigma 4 is smaller than Sigma 3 Sigma 2
and Sigma 1 so the stuff that I'm
throwing away are all smaller than the
things that I'm keeping okay so this is
the idea here the reason that this is so
important is that at any point that I
decide to truncate I'm guaranteed to
have the best possible rank 3
approximation to my matrix at that level
of truncation so if I throw if I only
keep the first three modes and the first
three singular values these are
guaranteed to be the
best three possible features in my data
they capture the most the most
information in this data there's no
other three use Sigma's and Vees that
will better approximate this matrix X
and if I wanted to keep five pieces of
information I would keep you know u4 u5
v4 v5 and Sigma 4 Sigma 5 finally to
keep 9 I would just keep 9 I can keep as
many as I like and throw away as many as
I like and I'm guaranteed that that's
the best approximation with that much
information possible ok so each of these
columns u1 is more important than u2
that's the more important than u3 that's
more important than u4 similarly with v1
v1 is more important than v2 and v3 than
before they're hierarchically ordered in
importance of how much they explain your
data X and the great thing about these
features is that they have the same
shape as my measurements my use are
exactly the same shape as my X's so for
example if X were a bunch of columns of
ovarian cancer data like all of your
gene expressions you one would be the
most important genes that Express
ovarian cancer you two would be the
second most important linear combination
of genes that expresses ovarian cancer
similarly for disease data a column of X
might have been the disease populations
in each of 500 districts in Nigeria so
u1 is the most important mixture or a
ratio of diseases in those districts u2
is the second most important that
explains my data that I've collected ok
same with stock markets and with
everything else if my data was collected
in time so if my data was collected in
time so you know x1 was at day 1 x2 was
day 2 XM was day M
then these rows of V correspond to time
histories okay these are the dominant
time patterns so for example if I take
the stock market data and I run it
through the singular value decomposition
there's two dominant modes that I see
over the last ten years any guesses what
the dominant modes are for the stock
market in the last ten years what
happened in the last ten years so there
was a huge crash in the stock market in
late 2008 I was sitting in a BMW
dealership getting ready to test drive a
car I couldn't afford at all when I saw
in the news that the stock market had
crashed okay so the first actual
dominant mode is gross the first
dominant mode in the stock market even
with the crash is growth and the second
dominant mode is a huge crash in
recovery okay
these are my V modes because those are
the time progression this is the
dominant time progression of all of my
use or at least a view one in you two
okay so these are our extremely
interpretable quantities the columns of
you are like my measurements they're the
most dominant linear combination of
measurements that show up in my data and
columns of V or rows of V star are the
time histories of those measurements the
dominant time histories that I see over
and over again so for example in the
disease you see a dominant one-year
cycle because there is a one-year you
know like cycle where people spread
diseases more more regularly okay
questions before we go on to some MATLAB
and some real actual examples yeah
Sigma's are the heaven was developed how
do you actually compute these things
yeah we're doing correlate to your rose
oh good so so first of all I'll just say
I just wrote a book chapter on the
singular value decomposition and I'm
gonna post sections of it on the website
if any of you want all of it you can
email me and everything I'm going to
derive here is like flushed out a lot
more detail and here
but the basic idea I told you that the
singular value decomposition is
measuring correlation between rows and
columns of X ok so my my u structures u
the U matrix is ordered and each column
of U is a dominant correlation between
columns of X ok so this measures
correlation among columns
of X and it doesn't in the following way
so if I want to measure correlation
among columns of X what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take X transpose star is
just a fancy transpose it's just the
transpose times X what is the size of X
star X sorry well I take this tall
skinny matrix that's n by M and I knock
it on its side so that's M by N and then
I multiply it by the tall skinny matrix
n by M so this is an M by n matrix and
it's a matrix of inner products this is
a big matrix M by M of X 1 transpose X 1
times X 2 transpose X 1
I think X 3 transpose X 1 dot X 1
transpose X 2 X 2 transpose X 2 dot dot
dot F at M ok
I literally just take every column of X
and I inner product it with every other
column of X and I build out this huge
matrix of inner products ok and if some
of these row if some of these columns
are really correlated with each other
then what should their inner products
look like they're gonna be very large
right so columns that are correlated
give large inner products columns that
are d correlated give small inner
products and so the idea is that let me
make sure that I get the math right so
the idea is that X
star x times V equals V Sigma squared
and we also have the X X star times u
equals u Sigma squared and I'm going to
call this Sigma Sigma a and Sigma B
they're slightly slightly different than
the real Sigma's that we wrote down so
the idea is that this is an eigen
decomposition ok X star X is a big
matrix X X star is another big matrix v
are eigenvectors of x star x and sigma
is a diagonal matrix of eigenvalues
similarly for x x star which is a much
bigger may be a million by million
matrix u are the eigenvectors and
Sigma's are the diagonal of eigenvalues
okay so V are you know eigenvectors and
Sigma squared are e values and similarly
here and so this one is going to be an M
by M matrix of eigenvalues on the
diagonal and you just take those m by m
eigenvalues take the square roots and
those are my Sigma's so that's basically
if the answer is that I take X star X
and I do a huge eigenvalue decomposition
i get the eigenvectors and then i get
the eigenvalues as the diagonal elements
of this matrix and those are my singular
values so my singular values are the
square roots of the eigenvalues of this
matrix this matrix will have a million
or you know a ton of eigenvalues but
most of them are going to be 0 it just
has to be you can prove it unless I had
a million snapshots in which case then I
could have a million real eigenvalues ok
so this is how you would actually
possibly compute it by hand there are
much much much better ways to compute
this in a computer
but this is the conceptual way that you
would actually get it I would take these
huge correlation matrices I do an eigen
decomposition and I get U and V and
Sigma yeah they're just different in the
size so Sigma a is an M by M Sigma B is
an N by n they have exactly the same
nonzero eigen values these are all
things you can prove and demonstrate if
you want ok so there's lots more I can
tell you about the singular value
decomposition for example I would never
actually compute it this way there's
lots of better ways to compute it and
I'll show you that on Wednesday but I
want to give you an example so in this
example what I'm going to do this is
kind of a simple example what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to take a matrix
so a really easy example of a matrix is
an image right an image is a matrix so
I'm gonna take x equals an image of my
dog his name is Mort he's Amish okay
so this is gonna be an image of my dog
Mort he's gonna have something like a
thousand by a thousand pixels and what
we're going to see is that lots of his
column vector vectors are correlated
right because he has correlated features
right if you look at one column it looks
like the next column and lots of his
rows are also column correlated so I can
apply the singular value decomposition
to approximate my dog Mort with a much
lower rank matrix and I can do image
compression in this way so I can say
that this really equals some u sub R
Sigma sub R V sub R transpose where I
just keep the first R columns instead of
the first thousand columns maybe I'll
keep the first 50 columns the first 50
singular values and I'll get a big
compression like a factor of twenty
compression
okay any questions while we code this up
okay
this is Mort and okay so we all know how
to read in images now we're gonna load
dog into a matrix a I'm going to convert
that matrix a into a grayscale just you
know numerical values into the matrix X
so X is my data matrix and then I'm
going to do the SVD so in MATLAB the SVD
is beautifully simple
it's one-line u comma s comma V equals
SPD of X so s is just Sigma because I
don't like typing Sigma okay and I'm
gonna plot my original dog and then what
I'm going to do is for R equals 5 20 and
100 I'm gonna I'm gonna create an
approximate morte with the first five
columns of U times the first five
singular values times the first five
columns of V Star and then I'll do that
for 20 and 100 makes sense so these are
rank five rank 20 and rank 100 matrix
approximations to Mort takes a little
while to do the SVD because mort's a
large file and so this is what we have
the original dog in the upper left
pretty crisp and clear if I only keep
five modes which is 0.58 percent of the
original data storage so this is a about
a 200 times compression it's a really
crummy dog terrible right like if you
can kind of almost convince yourself
that there's nose eyes and ears but
that's a stretch when I keep 2.3 percent
it looks like a grainy dog you can see
some of his features you definitely know
it's a dog but you can't tell everything
about him but then when I start to keep
more like a hundred features you
actually get a lot more resolution in
the image it's a little hard to see here
not perfect but you do see a lot of the
features you see like flecks of snow and
things like that you get whiskers with a
hundred modes okay so even complicated
matrices can be approximated by much
lower ranked matrices using the singular
value decomposition I wouldn't really
recommend the SVD for image compression
I'm just showing you this as an example
that illustrates the concept of low rank
matrix approximations really we would do
the fast Fourier transform and do FFT
image compression to be way way better
okay questions about this figure yes so
this is completely looking at
correlations in the columns and
correlations in the rows and that you
can kind of convince yourself that this
makes sense because let's say I take a
column right here in the dog midsection
where it's like white brown white brown
some stuff white well if I look just one
row to the right or you start one column
to the right or one column to the left
those are gonna have big in our products
with each other because the column to
the right and the column to the left are
also going to have a lot of white then
brown then white and brown then white
then you know they're gonna basically
look the same so there is a lot of
correlation in neighboring columns and
neighboring rows and if you look at the
five most dominant correlations you
actually see those patterns popping up I
see white brown what not quite as brown
white right like that is a that is one
feature that's that's creating that
entire back midsection and you also have
a pretty simple you know white dark
white dark feature okay so this really
is there are five rows and five columns
and you're taking linear combinations of
those to build up this Mort that's why
it looks kind of crummy
so another thing you can do is make this
plot of the singular values so I should
probably actually just do this so I
could plot on a semi-log y semi log y is
just log in the y-direction so I'm gonna
semi log Y the diagonal entries of X
okay these are my singular values so
maybe I should make them okay so what I
find is that my first singular value is
really really large ten to the five
that's a hundred thousand the next one
is a lot smaller ten to the four so the
first singular value is ten times bigger
than the second one the next one is
smaller smaller smaller so they are
ordered from smallest to biggest and
then eventually they get much much
smaller compared with this original one
okay oftentimes you'll want to plot the
cumulative sum so you do the cumulative
sum of the diagonal entries divided by
the sum and what you can find is this
plot on the right which shows you for
example the first mode the first column
of U in the first column of V account
for 28% of the information in the dog
twenty-eight percent of the raw
information content of that image is in
the first column of U in the first row
and then if I had two rows and two
columns I would get 34% if I had 3 I
would get 38 five gets me forty two
point four six percent of the total
information you know forty two's not
enough that's why it looks crappy but if
I go up to a hundred I see that I'm
actually getting about seventy-five
percent of the energy and the dog and I
just keeps getting better and better and
better and better the more modes the
more columns I include the better my
Morton approximation gets until I get to
a hundred percent warped
any any questions about this does it
make sense what we're doing now this was
a single image where we're looking at
correlations between his rows and
columns we could also put in many images
that have been reshaped into
extraordinarily large column vectors so
that's something we'll do so I could
take a picture in every single one of
your faces and I could create a big
column vector with a million pixels for
each one of you and I could have each of
those as my columns of X and then I
could do this same analysis and I could
find the dominant facial patterns that
are shared between all of you the
dominant facial correlations from
everyone in the class or I could take a
hundred pictures of just one of you and
different you know like expressions
happy sad angry and I could find your
individual dominant facial features okay
so that's what we're gonna do on Friday
that's called eigenfaces this is an
eigen based method eigen decomposition
and so those are eigen faces and that's
the basis for facebook facial
recognition and all the scary stuff that
robots are gonna do in the future it's
pretty pretty cool stuff so I told you a
lot about the singular value
decomposition today you can read more
about it I'm gonna post the first
section tonight on Wednesday we're gonna
talk about more about the correlations
and some real practical examples like
ovarian cancer and on Friday we're gonna
look at Augen faces and we're gonna
build our own facial recognition
software okay all right thank you